[Music]
let's go to carlos in
oh great we gotta go back to oklahoma
what's up carlos
hey how's it going dr john good how are
you
doing doing good hanging in there even
in oklahoma i can be here
yeah it's nice and nice and rainy out
here so is it really trying yeah
man
y'all needed that huh
yeah good deal all right what's up man
hey um
yeah i mean
i don't know i kind of don't know where
to start so i'll just kind of get
straight to the cannonball dude if hey
if you don't know how to jump in the
lake just cannonball that's the best way
yeah there you go
and so um just something that has been
happening between um me and my wife
is simply i've i've been i felt betrayed
simply because she's been keeping money
secret from me and spending
lots of amount of money
um without me knowing and it's can it's
a continuous thing and
she came back to me about two weeks two
weeks ago letting me know about it again
after you know we've talked
um two other times you know
kind of trying to budget and all this
stuff but it just keeps happening and so
i'm feeling kind of just
i don't know don't know what to do
feeling really down i know deep down
side this isn't like a
money problem i feel like it's
a lot deeper than that yeah and so
with that being said i have like some
feelings about it because i know it's
not a money problem but i just
need some guidance need some help about
certain thoughts that like i have
regarding this issue yeah um so dude
it's it's an integrity issue and it's an
honest honesty right
and
it's a fidelity issue
so the way i couch that is financial
infidelity she's cheating on you she's
lying to you yeah right yeah she's got
secrets
and i think you're very very wise
um to see this the money is just the
symptom of a much bigger issue going on
um when you guys
meet up tell me how these like so you
you get together to have a budget which
all all budget means is y'all have a
plan for how you want your life to go
and you have some dreams of what you
want your life to look like right so you
you reverse engineer that all that
starts with like sunday nights we're
going to say how are we going to
do money this week where is she getting
this pocket of money that she's
hiding from you
uh credit cards uh she did tell me that
she got a personal loan through her bank
which are things that i
didn't know about she just went ahead
and did it behind me yeah what was she
buying
so that's kind of where i wanted to go
kind of just get a give you some context
so
we we've been together four years we're
almost two years married now
we went to therapy together
while we were dating and also when we
were married but there was a hiccup
there where she didn't like therapy
anymore because she felt
like the therap the therapist and i were
like teaming up against her and stuff
like that so that kind of came tumbling
down she doesn't like accountability
does she
um
i guess
i like i i feel i feel bad this is you
know i feel bad because i love my wife i
know i know i'm just like oh and hey i i
feel i i don't feel bad but i feel
i don't like talking bad about some
dude's wife right so when i ask these
questions i'm not it's not me being like
oh dude it's not like that
but it's me saying like you're married
to somebody that does not like
accountability and right feels trapped
by that and really doesn't want people
telling her what to do and you know who
does that also my six-year-old daughter
yeah it's a very immature way to to
navigate the world because it's not a
reality it's not a recognition of adult
reality right
right right and so going to answer your
question what's she spending this on so
after that whole hiccup with the
therapist happened um she has friends
that are
life coaches you know mindset coaches
and she expressed that you know talking
to them was
like in one session helped her more than
therapy ever did and so
ever since she got started getting
involved in that
she's like i want to become one so
that's what she's spending on she has
spent thousands and thousands of dollars
on courses to become a life coach
and just things like that and so she has
like
this career that she wants to get in
mind
and like i'll support her but she feels
like i don't support her when i say like
we can't buy this certain course what
i'd like to happen is
let's save the money and then when you
have the money let's go ahead and pay
that like i'm all for that but she just
wants everything now now now let me get
this like make sure i'm on the right
page
she is pursuing
a job
that helps people
become whole
um
align their personal and professional
lives align and manage relationships
and
um
create new identities in order to uh
to meet their goals
she's pursuing this job
by lying to her husband
taking out personal loans buying things
she can't afford putting herself and her
husband in some pretty significant um
financial
risk
um so that she can tell other people how
to live their lives with integrity
correct i mean if you put it that way
madness right i mean it's madness right
um right
and it doesn't surprise me so i actually
work with a coach
and very intentionally this coach is not
my friend
so of course it felt good to talk to
your friend who happens to be a coach
because you know what friends do
friends are like yeah
bullcrap that's what friends do right
right they swing first and then they're
like why did we hit that guy that's what
friends do now great friends will also
say hey before i hit that dude why are
we hitting this guy um but
they feel good that's what friends are
for supporting you up
uh therapy therapy is uncomfortable
especially when you don't like
accountability
and
your wife doesn't lie she doesn't like
that man here's the deal you are
you love this woman
you also use words like hiccup
it is not a hiccup
when your wife quits therapy on you
you know what i mean
that's a temper tantrum
i'm taking my ball and i'm going home
because you said hey this is important
to
us coming together here we've got some
issues she said sure i'm in and then
she's like i quit
um
you not supporting her is different than
we can't afford this those are two
different stories
right and now there's some gaslighting
going on where she's trying to make you
feel crazy
you're looking at the math and the math
says we can't afford these things
and
she's going to put math aside and say
you don't like me you don't fault right
so let me ask you this is there
something beneath this layer
because it feels like there is
yeah yeah i mean um this is my first
marriage this i'm her third she's been
divorced twice i i know a little bit of
what happened and everything carlos
brothers next time you gotta lead with
that that's super hell that's super
helpful my bad is that sorry
yeah i was just trying to do the
cannonball like you said yeah you can't
evolve but you only got halfway in like
part of you hit the hit the lake when
you i mean the lamb jumped in um yeah so
my guess is a lot in there there's a lot
in there so
um and that's kind of where
like i'm trying not to get emotional but
it's kind of hard for me because right
now i feel like
like this career
is definitely like it's feeling like
it's definitely
above me
um
and
like she's doing her thing like she has
her own agenda
um even if i ask like hey like i support
you but let's let's just wait a little
bit so we can make that money because
we're already in debt from the last time
you did this
um
but she kind of just says
well
if she did one time come and talk to me
about something about a purchase that
she wanted to get i told her let's wait
she's like well i'm doing it and so i
feel like she doesn't really
like respect my
opinion or like respect my
i don't i don't even know what to call
it but i respect my authority yeah
it doesn't feel like that she absolutely
doesn't care
and i know this hurts to hear that
because you love her and that's your
wife
um
but you are a springboard to the life
that she wants to lead and the moment
you try to partner up with her which is
what marriage is she says
i'm not doing the partner thing i'm
doing whatever the hell i want to do
right and if you don't want to be along
for that ride
a there's two more
in the shadows
you can be number three that's fine
if you don't want to get along for that
ride you're the crazy one you're the
jerk you're the not supportive one
you're the you know you're the mean guy
trying to oppress me and hold me down
um
here's the old like brother
you and i could talk for a long time
here ultimately here's where the
question lies it is um
are you in
or do you have a or what moment
do you have a line somewhere
i've been in from the start um but with
all these things happening like i feel
like that line is just little by little
creeping it yes to be honest like i can
100 tell you i've been in from the start
i knew what i
you know was getting into i knew like
her trauma and i feel like it as it
you know as it just kept going it just
got worse and worse and worse and
i don't know it's just
yeah i mean i'm just trying to be super
honest with you like right and
appreciate that brother that is
but that line yeah you can be turning in
and somebody else can be edging you out
right
um yes the other the other thing is this
i
just so we're clear i'm not just banging
on your wife
um
dude she may have been i don't know
this is a whole other conversation you
and i could have off like
she may have been abused in these other
marriages in these other relationships
and she circled the wagons and said this
will never happen
again
and she may have hit that pendulum too
far
no man will ever tell me what i can and
can't do because i paid the price for
that physically psychologically who
knows what that past is
the reality though is
y'all are here
right so the path forward is you sitting
down with a very clear or what moment
this is gonna change or i'm gonna go
or you got to be completely honest with
yourself and say
even if this doesn't change i'm going to
stay
and then it becomes much more about
management on your end
so let's take it and make it much less
personal for you i hear people call and
say hey my um
my wife and all these my husband's
gained 110 pounds
i love him
i'm no longer physically or sexually
attracted to him at all
and i don't know what to do
one of the starting places i always
start are you going to leave
and sometimes people are like yeah i'm
really kind of getting that's one track
the other is i will never leave no
matter what i'm here ride or die
that's a different conversation see what
i'm saying
right and so you gotta ask yourself
where is that line and don't let it
sneak up on you you just gotta be honest
with yourself and with your wife and say
here's what this line is and then you
got to be really clear about here's what
getting on the same page means that
we're doing this thing together i'm 100
guaranteeing you that her experiences as
a life coach will fail
because she's not living the principles
that she will be taught to teach other
people
and
you can't oh i mean ultimately you have
to live the principles that you're
teaching right or
you can you can limp and and prop it up
but it's going to fall over
right right and so
ultimately you got to say here's where
we are here's what we're going to be
about and
um i need you involved
or else
have you have you pictured yourself or
else
i have
i have before okay
um i don't like to think about it i feel
guilty doing it yeah can i ask you a
real hard question
absolutely um
do you have somebody else in mind
already
uh
like like another person yep
no no
does she
i would say no
i don't think she does
you were less confident about that
answer
well it's just because
i mean i
i i don't think it was like less
confident i feel like
i feel hurt right now that i just can't
trust her so my mind's going everywhere
there you go okay okay and i'm just like
uh well i don't know i i can't trust her
right so maybe uh okay okay i'm just
saying maybe you know what i mean yeah
yeah yeah yeah totally yeah and that's
the problem
yeah so yeah this
it's a good sign then because often i
ask that question and i'll hear a pause
and then
the dude will be like yeah i work with
her and that what i don't want you to do
is get to a place where you find
yourself compromising your values
because you're you know your
your home is on fire i'd rather you just
deal with the fire and then let's make
some some adult decisions moving on so
let me just ask you man what are you
gonna do
what's this look like
um well i i talked to her um already
when i've found this out and
um
so i i made some plans with her and she
said it's like she's good with it so
i told her like hey
we're gonna talk about this in front of
a therapist
um and we'll we'll do it that way and
we'll figure things out that's honestly
all i've
have planned because
talking about this her career and she's
really sensitive to it so if i
say anything about it that might that
might she might take it wrong and it's
just no conversation just doesn't go
anywhere
it sounds like your home is one where
you have to walk on eggshells in your
home in your own house
absolutely and it's true your home
should be a place where you can drop
your shoulders and say
right i can i can exhale because we've
got to walk on an eggshell sometimes at
our jobs and sometimes with dealing with
people that are tough to deal with
our homes should be there right that's
where we drop our shoulders right
yeah
i i would recommend writing this out
and that way at the first counseling
session you can tell the therapist i've
read i've written a letter and i think
in that letter you should talk about
i've lost trust and i don't feel safe in
this relationship
and those are not
bro things to say those are not very
oklahoma and masculine things to say but
they're true
right right um and you can say somebody
asked me if you were cheating on me and
my first thought was no but then i
thought
but maybe
right and that'd be a big oh my gosh i
can't believe you would say that about
and then it's going to be a re-diversion
to you and what's wrong with you
but the reality is there's just this
lack of trust and is the air we breathe
i also think it would be fair to say if
you quit therapy again i'm taking that
as a sign you're quitting on us
because we're not okay
right and i think that's a very fair
boundary for you to draw
right and i have a quick question with
everything you're saying so
um
one thing that that
i guess
which is a struggle for me too is
she she tells me she's sorry but in a in
a way she's she
like i don't know the actions don't say
it so listen listen listen behavior is a
language
behavior is a language
my wife can come up and say you're such
a [ __ ]
while she's hugging me and giving me a
kiss
and
her actions are way more important than
her words
and she can also say no i'm not mad
while she's slamming the cabinets right
behavior's a language right and your
wife can say whatever she wants
but she doesn't have any respect for you
more importantly she doesn't have any
not more importantly but equally
important she has any respect for the
unity the relationship y'all have
right
um
she seems to only respect whatever the
crap she wants to do in whatever moment
she wants to do it in
yeah yeah i feel like she holds this
career her coaching but hey if you take
the career away my i bet a million bucks
there's been things in the past
she still tupperware did mary kay was
gonna go get another degree and nursing
was gonna do something else this is just
the latest thing to distract herself
gotcha right and it feels good and
there's all these promises about you can
make a billion dollars and you can
become an influencer and you can't
and when you're when you're first in
counseling first in coaching it feels
like a super power like oh i know why
everybody's doing what you don't but it
feels that way because you're learning
all the stuff so it feels good right now
right and then she can start meeting
with clients and it's going to get messy
real fast that's just that's just a
prediction maybe i'm totally wrong maybe
she's going to be incredible at it um
and she's maybe i don't think she's a
psychopath hopefully she's not but
um
yeah this is just the latest thing
is that true
no yeah it's not very true it's it
wasn't anything
during our dating life it wasn't
anything like you know it's just sprung
forth out of nowhere and all of a sudden
this is
what she's called to do and so so let me
give you this so i was the i graduated
with a phd i was done with school i'm
done
got my little fancy pants doctor degree
i was the dean of students at a law
school working with my students taking
care of people
and i really like in my gut
felt like
i need to figure out what's going on
with me what's going on with my family
what's going on with my marriage what's
going on with my friends going to the
country and my students so i started
nickel and diamond my way i just took a
free class
in counseling and i rolled up i started
in the master's program and they just
rolled me up into the phd program
when i finally was like hey i'm going
all in on this i'm gonna go ahead and
get a second phd that was a very hard
season for me and my wife and we had to
calculate the finances of it all the
time of it all it was something we very
much had to do together and she wasn't
on board she didn't want me to do it
she's like you've already done this and
i felt this drive but the drive couldn't
override my responsibility i had to a
young kid to a marriage that was
struggling to finances we when we owed a
bunch of people money like
it was hard to do and so we had to
navigate that together
right see what i'm saying so i had that
same drive i wanted to go do this thing
and i had a path laid out for me and
still had to be an adult about how i
moved forward in it i couldn't just say
oh my gosh really and just take out a
bunch of loans and and when i
and i've come to learn this the last
five or six years and embarrassingly or
four last four or five years
if i'm starting to do something send a
text make a phone call go to a store and
my first thought is
i haven't told my wife yet or i don't
need to tell her about this
i definitely need to tell her about it
because that means i'm hiding something
right
yeah
yeah i agree and so i bought two water
bottles like two nights ago off amazon
yeah i read some study about the
chemicals from plastics and i was like
did i get some gloss here it is right i
look upset it's right here on my desk
and i ordered it and i thought
we have so many water bottles my wife's
gonna kill me and dude i ordered them
anyway
and i've that's a minor thing but it's a
thing that i did knowing there was going
to be a bigger conversation and that if
i'd asked my wife about it she would
have said hey what if we waited until
we did our next budget we had the money
for it it's not like we're broke so i
didn't go take a loan out for it but it
was just a little bitty thing and i had
to tell her i'm sorry i shouldn't have
ordered yet another thing
right you see what i'm saying
yeah i'm telling you because i'm telling
you all this you're not crazy
and you're not weak and you're not a
[ __ ] and you're not some kind of lame
like whiny
whatever and you're not crapping on your
wife's dreams or anything like that
sounds like you are all in you just want
to be all in together with your wife and
that's that i totally support that um
and i think you're right to tell your
wife
the line the cliff for us is coming up
really quick and so before it sneaks up
on us we're going to see a counselor
which i think you're super wise to do i
think the next step is to write that
letter out and there's gonna be a lot of
anger in that letter a lot of rage a lot
of frustration a lot of
um
uh
emotion and feeling in that i think
that's good and then you're gonna read
that letter to her in front of the
therapist and say here's where i am um
i'm not interested in moving forward if
you're going to continue to be a person
i can't trust
or i am going to move forward but i'm
going to get my own finances and you're
going to be like right i'm going to have
to create this world so that i can live
in that world that nobody wants to live
like that man so
um do this let me know how that first
counseling session goes i mentioned in
the follow up there
to everybody listening if you've
i've said it before
i i've come to believe infidelity is a
much bigger thing than who kissed who
then who made out with who who hooked up
with who
infidelity is
am i in this
um am i all in
and
am i all in with my money am i all in
with my finances i'm all in with being
honest am i all in with letting my needs
be heard am i all in with my actions
trying to meet my partner's needs am i
all in
on am i all in
do i hold things back and
fidelity has become just such a much
bigger thing to me as i meet with
couples all over the country
people are living these really
fragmented messy marriages and then
they're going to counseling trying to
fix the anxiety or trying to fix their
frustration or trying to fix this or
that
and man
when you try to be 17 different people
at the same time it's exhausting and
it's just
melting relationships
if you're gonna be all in be all in
fidelity is about integrity and
integrity is about is the root is the
word integer it means whole it means the
circle never stops right
be all in
and if somebody that you're connected to
is not all in be willing to have the
hard uncomfortable conversation
um sooner rather than later